ah je vais toujours dit par contre les
mois qu'on a passé à être intime et
proche je lui dis il faut ralentir parce
qu'un jour ça te tuera
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le concours de Miss Belgique était visé
par un attentat terroriste ouais en fait
j'arrive j'arrive dans la salle pour
aller chercher un ami et là je remarque
beaucoup de policiers et pas des
policiers locaux c'est des policiers
fédéraux comme on dit chez nous donc ils
ont d'autres insignes donc on sait que
c'est grave qu'il y a quelque chose qui
se passe là on me dit ben écoute il y a
une alerte à la bombe il faut évacuer
toute la salle qu'à partir de ce
moment-là on évacue
on se retrouve dehors et et là on
panique on commence à paniquer parce que
là on nous dit alerte à la bombe on est
dehors derrière le bâtiment derrière
coulisse et on se dit qu'est-ce qu'on
fait donc on attend dans le froid avec
le costume avec la robe on avait rien
sur nous comme vous l'avez dit il va
tuer de la salle vous attendez dehors et
un homme a été arrêté près du théâtre
avec plusieurs armes sans sa possession
c'est surtout ça qui est important aussi
la police l'avait repéra à cause de
messages dans le contenu qui est laissé
penser à une attaque terroriste ouais et
on apprend ça effectivement et donc là
c'est encore plus la panique parce que
est-ce qu'il est tout seul et ce qui a
plusieurs personnes on ne le sait pas on
m'a prévenu le commissaire m'a dit 5
minutes si on n'était pas arrivé dans
les 5 minutes vous étiez dedans parce
qu'il était déterminé en fait le gars le
gars était sur le parking il se
dirigeait vers la salle il était
déterminé donc
à partir de ce moment là
c'est très très compliqué en fait de se
retrouver sur sur le plateau et devoir
faire son métier d'animateur je me suis
dit quitte à mourir autant mourir avec
moitié mourir sur scène je me suis dit
je m'en fous il y a 5 % de chance on est
en sécurité mais il y a quand même ce
petit cette petite peur et donc je monte
sur son château on le fait mais je le
fais voilà il faut garder le sourire il
faut rien montrer à l'antenne je me suis
excusé auprès des spectateurs mais il
faut garder cette phase
ici au début je dis effectivement qu'il
y avait eu des menaces etc mais on en a
pas fait tout un plat il y a des
techniciens qui sont partis de peur je
peux pas leur en vouloir merci à eux
d'ailleurs mais ils sont partis ils sont
rentrés à la maison je me suis retrouvé
sans personne dans l'oreillette depuis
deux jours vous me dites les journées
sont difficiles
ben ouais les journées sont difficiles
surtout j'ai pas dormi de samedi à
dimanche parce que ça travaille et puis
à un moment donné voilà je me retrouve
ici j'aurais vraiment aimé être là et
vous rencontrez et venir déconner et
faire le point mérite pas dans ces
circonstances là c'est voilà il avait il
avait 90 balles sur lui non balle avec 5
chargeurs
et donc les miss elles ont été mises au
courant avant la cérémonie est-ce qu'il
y en a qui ont paniqué est-ce qu'elles
ont été dit moi je tiens juste à dire
une chose je suis hyper impressionné de
ces gonzesses quoi mais on a pensé
effectivement au plan et à ce qui s'est
passé je ne compare pas le Bataclan j'ai
juste eu les images ça il faut que ce
soit clair les images de ce qui s'est
passé j'ai vu des documentaires par
centaines et donc c'est la première
chose à laquelle on pense et donc donc
voilà
Michel Marie merci d'être avec nous
reporter nouveau détective pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent à
20h52 qu'est-ce qui s'est passé le
témoignage de Jérémy et que ça monte
Pierre Palmade alors qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé Pierre Palmade avait acheté une
maison à Cély-en-Bière en 2017 pour fuir
justement ce monde de la nuit le monde
de des nuits parisiennes avec la coque
etc
et en fait ça n'a pas fonctionné
puisqu'il organisait des fêtes dans sa
dans sa maison et il découvre que le
frigo est vide et donc ils ont besoin de
de s'alimenter d'aller faire des courses
c'est au retour alors que c'est la une
petite départementale des 372 qui est
qui est tout droite enfin c'est assez
impressionnant qu'on puisse avoir un
accident sur cette route là il va se
déporter pour des raisons que j'ignore
se déportés sur la gauche et
avoir un choc frontal avec un autre
véhicule qui était conduit par un homme
de 40 ans son fils était à l'arrière un
fils de 6 ans et en passager une femme
enceinte âgée de 26 ans qui était
enceinte de moi alors que s'est-il passé
est-ce qu'il y a eu consommation
notamment de produits qui s'appelle le
camsex pour favoriser justement alors
c'est ce que c'est ce qui se dit c'est
quoi cette histoire de sexe lequel c'est
un mot-valise qui veut dire Camille
c'est la contraction de Camille colle et
sexual je veux dire d'accord des
produits chimiques et une activité
sexuelle on prend des drogues on prend
des substances pour être performant
sexuellement on va faire on va faire des
marathons ce qu'on appelle des marathons
sexuels ça peut durer moi je soigner des
patients qui faisaient 96 heures
d'affilée le marathon quoi d'accord
apparemment apparemment effectivement il
y aurait eu il y aurait eu un
conditionnel consommation de tels
produits dans la maison de Pierre
Palmade à Céliane bien c'est que Pierre
Palmade et responsable à 100% de cet
accident donc les les conclusions en
dehors de prier de souhaiter que ces
gens-là non seulement ne meurent pas
mais n'est pas trop trop de séquelles
trop grave
comment vous avez fait pour le
rencontrer
moi Pierre Palmade moi je suis montée
sur Paris en fait pour faire carrière
dans la mode dans le mannequinat et
c'est vrai que j'ai voulu absolument
essayer de l'approcher essayer de le
connaître mais juste personnellement ça
peut avoir des conseils juste d'accord
donc comment vous avez fait pour la
prochaine très simple je suis né à l'air
de la nouvelle technologie c'était par
Instagram vous étiez ensemble ou pas
vous étiez pas du tout ensemble mais on
se voyait comme si qu'on était en effet
ensemble d'accord on a toujours gardé
cette liberté on est d'accord il aimait
aussi
se ressourcer justement dans sa maison à
la campagne est-ce que vous avez fait
déjà fait des soirées comme on en a
comme ça dont on a parlé en le côtoyant
je suis tombé dans certains excès c'est
quoi les excès c'est que c'est c'était
plus d'alcool c'était à toucher et
essayer la cocaïne
n'aviez jamais touché avant avant non
avant jamais moi je vais toujours dit
par contre les mois qu'on a passé à être
intime et proches je lui dis il faut
ralentir parce qu'un jour ça te tuera et
donc c'est vrai que quand j'ai su cette
nouvelle au début je voulais pas y
croire mais je me suis dit c'est pas
impossible et puis après quand il y a
les sites sérieux quand on parlait je me
suis bah c'est une évidence finalement
et là il a que 1000 réparable c'est de
d'avoir pris autant de danger et de
faire des victimes
aujourd'hui la quincagénaire est marié
avec gabano un mannequin et ancien
candidat de téléréalité de 39 ans une
relation que les deux tourtereaux
assument pleinement à la base c'était
pas du tout de la drague
tu as craqué
ce qui vous a dit il m'a dit si je viens
à Marseille c'est peut-être pour
rencontrer la femme de ma vie je me suis
dit ouh là le beau parleur
on parle de la différence de l'âge donc
je suis obligé de vous demander un
message donc 39 ans pour toi
tu as des nouvelles de Dolce
[Rires]
le soir de Halloween
et vous êtes marié vraiment marine
vraiment c'était
sérieusement réellement vous marier
sérieusement on y pense
alors j'ai à la base les magasins de
prêt-à-porter et puis je travaille sur
les plateformes de charme d'accord très
bien et toi
là je suis sur les plateformes de charme
aussi d'accord avec Nathalie
on fait des photos des vidéos donc voilà
donc tous les deux et en solo
et puis à la base il est venu me parler
pour parler des plateformes
c'est jamais rencontré du tout du tout
vraiment pas exactement ce qui est
complètement fou c'est que tu l'as dit
Nathalie donc on peut le dire c'est que
ça te rapporte plus plusieurs centaines
de milliers d'euros par mois
entre 300 et 500000 à peu près non pas
loin peut-être par an par mois combien
de 150 000 par mois
ça vaut bien c'est effectivement dans le
cas de Leonardo DiCaprio parce qu'il est
toujours avec des nanas qui ont 19 20
ans également
DiCaprio frère
très connu qui était très jeune après la
différence d'âge
bien sûr moi j'ai 20 ans
là il a 20 ans de différence avec la
personne qui l'aime bien sûr j'ai 53 ans
aucun problème moi je veux dire que ça
pose problème quand la personne est très
jeune et qui a 20 25 ans d'écart parce
que à un moment donné il y a pas de
discussion il y a pas de suivi c'est pas
comme nous on a présenté et voilà mais
on a beaucoup de choses à se raconter il
a passé j'ai un passé on a des choses à
te raconter une fille de 20 ans elle a
rien à raconter à son mari car elle a 50
elle a pas de passer elle a pas de vécu
à un moment donné ça va choquer voilà
moi honnêtement moi ça me dérange pas
chacun fait ce qu'il veut mais ça serait
ma fille ça me ferait quoi ah c'est ça
moi les excuses vous imaginez bien
qu'elle n'aurait pas en rien
qui avait qui avait une vie devant lui
[Musique]
les yeux rouges Ramadan jusqu'il le
regard de ma daronne snapchat
ce qui est grave c'est que Tik Tok
refuse de prendre conscience d'un
phénomène ultra dangereux parce que ça
peut créer des angiomes ça peut être
très très
dangereux et créer créer de graves
maladies pour ces jeunes et Tik Tok
refusent de considérer ça comme de
l'automutilation alors qu'il devrait
interdire ce phénomène c'est ça qui est
grave parce que tout de suite tu as une
émission devient plus rassera oui et
puis c'est dangereux mais c'est surtout
stupide et moi je trouve que c'est une
insulte
qui sont vraiment pas en victimes aux
hommes victimes de coups à ceux qui sont
qui sont dans des je sais pas dans des
accidents qui ont des dommages corporels
et je trouve que c'est vraiment une mode
de petits bourgeois à la con quoi
franchement non mais c'est débile c'est
aboutissant et en même temps ça résume
bien ça
je pense que là-dedans il y a aussi le
fait que quand on est trop sur TiK ToK
on a plus rien à dire donc on s'avance
une vie on se moque un storytelling et
là dedans je vois aussi des jeunes qui
sont ça pour que le lendemain on dise ah
mais tu as une cicatrice qu'est-ce qui
t'es arrivé donc ça résume c'est n'avoir
rien à dire et faire n'importe quoi pour
se qu'on s'intéresse à soi chaque époque
a eu ces conneries et c'était aussi con
avant de regarder c'était aussi con
avant et là il y a la scarification ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui a une
signification psychologique chez
l'enfant et tout ça là bon pour ça comme
un gros suçon c'est débile ça peut
rester à vie un gros un gros suçon ici
c'est un peu relou Mathieu je suis très
choqué parce que tu nous traites de
vieux cons Guillaume et moi tu dis tu es
jeune tu connais tu comprends les
nouvelles tendances mais tu as vu la le
visage de ce jeune garçon là avec la
joue complètement
que ce soit un enfant battu par exemple
non mais arrête ça s'appelle des
suppositions si on dit pas de
supposition du tout ça veut dire que ça
va être une escalade ça veut dire qu'il
y a des gens qui vont pas oser dire
qu'ils sont battus en disant moi je fais
le challenge
à mon époque dans l'école c'était cap ou
pas cap si vous voulez jouer de bonhomme
tu les écartes alors moi ça avait
commencé par Cap d'avaler une bille bam
je la vallée
ou pas cap qu'on fait entre potes à un
réseau social débile qui coupe le
travail avec des gens qui sont des
débits des des défis abrutissants pour
des gens qui connaissent même pas c'est
dangereux Tik Tok tu vois bien Mathieu
quand même 350 000 personnes
tu as pensé dernière chose je te laisse
à l'époque je te préférais tout à
l'heure à l'époque MacGyver 182 épisodes
qui passent ce soir j'adorerais il y
avait des Américains à la con qui
disaient bah oui mais les enfants qui
regardent ils peuvent faire une bombe ou
machin ou gnagnagna je crois qu'il y a
un mot qui s'est blessé en 20 ans
arrêtez de penser parce qu'il y a 350000
personnes qui regardent il y a 350 000
cons qui vont se faire ça le jeu du
foulard on pense au départ que ça
exactement
[Musique]
alors Pierre Palmade est sorti de de
réanimation il est actuellement il a été
transféré dans un service de chirurgie
d'ici est Steve il est placé sous
contrôle PS psychologique puisque
évidemment les médecins ont peur qu'ils
fassent une tentative de suicide et là
d'autres examens ont été faits pour
savoir si les policiers vont pouvoir
bientôt l'entendre dans le dans le cadre
d'une garde à vue et s'il va pouvoir
être présenté devant le juste
instruction quelles sont les nouvelles
mois de vous êtes l'avocat de la famille
des victimes de l'accident on en est où
aujourd'hui les nouvelles elles sont pas
bonnes Siri d'abord on a une passagère
qui a perdu son bébé elle était censée
accoucher le 14 mai d'un enfant d'une
petite fille et aujourd'hui cet enfant a
perdu la vie à la suite de cet accident
il va y avoir d'abord une autopsie qui
va être réalisée sur sur le bébé c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement dur et
douloureux pour les familles évidemment
ils imaginaient le 14 mai célébré la
naissance de cette petite fille qui a
été choyé par ses parents qui étaient
attendus plus que tout dans ce cocon
d'amour dans ce foyer qui attendait ce
premier enfant comme comme on attend un
événement heureux et donc là ils vont
devoir être confrontés dans les
prochaines heures à une autopsie du bébé
et donc c'est cette autopsie qui va dire
de façon formelle et définitive si
effectivement le bébé est né viable et
donc effectivement de deux choses l'une
soit le bébé n'est pas névable auquel
cas effectivement il y a la
jurisprudence de 2001 qui s'applique et
l'infraction de de domicile involontaire
ne veut pas être tenu ou alors comme je
le pense comme on le pense comme les
éléments qui nous reviennent semblent le
démontrer l'enfant est né viable et donc
par conséquent il y aurait la
qualification de homicide involontaire
qui pourrait être retenu contre Monsieur
Palmade auquel cas il encourait une
peine de 10 ans d'emplacement la maman
elle est dévastée physiquement d'abord
des vertèbres abîmées une entorse de
coup des côtes fêlés enfin elle est dans
un état pitoyable et désastreux
physiquement et puis pour les autres
c'est encore pire parce que le
conducteur il a été broyé entre le
volant et et le fauteuil et le gamin à
l'arrière qui a 6 ans qui est le fils du
conducteur il est d'après les dire de sa
mère c'est complètement défiguré et dans
le conducteur il est dans quel état là
il est très mal en 72 heures je crois
qu'il en est à 5 ou 7 opérations c'est
ça les excuses vous imaginez bien
qu'elle n'aurait pas en rien
qui avait qui avait une vie devant lui
c'est important de le dire l'enfant de 6
ans qui était dans le véhicule défiguré
ce que je sais aujourd'hui c'est que il
a la mâchoire complètement détruite et
que vraisemblablement visuellement c'est
plus tout à fait le même donc voilà ça
va être très compliqué pour cet enfant
de se reconstruire
vous aviez vu cette affiche ou pas cette
affiche
moi vraiment je suis venu ce soir c'est
ça me fait vraiment pas ça me fait même
pas plaisir de venir pour de vrai c'est
juste que je vois comment mon quartier
en gros il est affiché partout ça fait
pas plaisir c'est ça des gens sur leur
adresse ils ont pas de l'opico avenue
Pablo Picasso ils vont aller chercher du
travail tout ça des gens de mon âge des
jeunes tout ça finalement ils peuvent se
faire refouler pour ça c'est à dire
cacahuète que quand il y a des gens qui
viennent de ton quartier parfois il y a
une discrimination on lui prend même pas
pour travailler tout ça moi j'ai pas dit
ça mais ça peut arriver là j'étais sur
BFM je me suis réveillé un matin j'étais
sur BFM j'ai vu les dealers du quartier
Pablo Picasso ça c'est pas un truc
ils font des journées
il y a plein d'artistes il y a des
mannequins il y a plein de trucs il y a
des concerts qui sont et on a retenu que
ça en fait et on retient que ça tout ça
il y a aussi ça mais ça est-ce que c'est
une Nanterre ou c'est partout en gros on
se fait un fichier comme si en gros à
Nanterre en gros c'était il y a dentaire
que ça se passait
Picasso en gros tout le quartier il y a
des gens ils ont rien à voir là il y a
depuis là il y a des renforcement
policiers des choses comme ça
il y a des trucs qui sont pas nécessaire
en fait ça il y a des trucs qui
utilisent laine je sais pas comment on
dit non mais au-delà de ce point-là ce
qui est choquant c'est le thon du
règlement qui circule et en fait on a
l'impression que c'est tellement
démocratisé qu'on a l'impression que
c'est devenu un commerce comme un autre
ça parle d'employé ça parle d'horaire on
a l'impression qu'il parle du travail et
c'est eux qui dicte la loi c'est
complètement hallucinant là où la police
a du mal à malheureusement à se faire
respecter vous avez l'impression qu'en
gros c'est choquant vous voulez que je
fasse quoi ah mais rien moi je suis
juste venu vous dire
justement pour votre sécurité enfin pour
votre tranquillité quand qu'on
s'inquiète pour votre façon en gros
c'est pour ne tranquillité consacrer
vous dites c'est pour moi de
tranquillité là que je suis là mais au
final je suis pas tranquille là je vais
repartir là ça se trouve là je vais me
faire arrêter par la parce que là je
vous explique je dis pas que c'est tous
les policiers mais dans ce problème dans
ce pays on sait qu'il y a des problèmes
avec la police et les jeunes moi ce que
je vous dis juste c'est que là là pour
le bout de papier kangourou qui a été
affiché là là aujourd'hui là je peux
rentrer chez moi me faire contrôler ou
pour rien il y a des renforcements
policiers c'est grave ça c'est normal
qu'il est renforcé il y a eu un
renforcement policier à cause papier là
il y a beaucoup de il y a beaucoup
d'accusation des jeunes qui vont se
faire contrôler pour rien comme vous
vous avez dit argenté et tout ça c'est
pas la même chose mais moi je vous dis
plein à Nanterre par exemple je peux me
faire contrôler mais quand on écoute
tous les gens dans le lieu ou dans les
cités
déjà dans les cités ça se passe toujours
très très bien on montre que le mauvais
il y a des gens formidables c'est pas
vrai ça se passe pas comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]